Widow of Alexander ludwinenko the former
FSB agent who turned critic of the
Kremlin and was murdered here in London
there was suspected to have been signed
off by Vladimir Putin himself now you
know better than most the personal toll
it can take for someone to criticize the
Kremlin what would you say to people who
say well why aren't more Russians taking
to the streets against the war
I think it's a very important Russian
people came to say they are against of
this war because after Invasion started
a year ago it was image of Russian
people as all people supported Putin or
they just try to be neutral and they
don't want to say anything to support to
Ukraine it's not true a lot of Russia
now supporting Ukraine they're doing
everything for Ukraine will win and this
meets in front of Russian Embassy makes
this possibility to Russian people to
say this and to show this they are
against the war other side many Russian
people who lives in Russia so
frightening to go outside and talking
about this war was they really to
believe and this is just a very good
support to them to see all Russians who
have chance to say openly what they
think and they are against the war might
do this and this is like for them for
Russian who is in Russia now just
supported them who just can't say this
and message to all International
Community Russian against the war and
you don't need to support Putin or make
any explanation why he started this war
is not not any doubt nor any doubt Putin
is crime War crime and do you think that
maybe some Russians within Russia feel I
guess attacked by maybe some in the
International Community that attacks
they equalize attacks against future
attacks against ordinary Russians it's a
blurring of those lines in a sense
no it's um you know after what happened
to Ukraine and particularly in one year
what we see what happened to civilians
how many people died many people have to
escape from Ukraine it's all what
happened to to us sometimes it's just a
little everything what we need to do now
to sing how to help Ukrainian even if so
many Russians escaped from Russia now
because they disagree with the war and
sometimes might feel inconvenience or
difficulties or even being under
sanctions I would say it's just a little
to compare what Ukrainian people feeling
and why was it important for you to be
here today as well I see many many young
people here and different faces when
they started all processed 10 years ago
15 years ago it was not a big crowd it
was maybe people who came to United
Kingdom as a dissident but now I can see
more and more young people who disagree
with the Putin's regime and this is the
future of Russia and when we're talking
about you Russia these people would be
back to Russia and build this a new
Russia in International Community and do
you think an event like this is not just
support for the Ukrainian people but
also an attempt to fight for as many
people here said a more democratic
future in Russia and perhaps break some
of those stereotypes that maybe exist
around Russians in the west oligarchs
and stuff like that you're absolutely
right right Russia would be new after
Ukraine will win
it's no way it's no way Ukraine will win
Putin's regime will be crushed and just
away when new Russia would be started to
rise